[Music]
everybody going in wake up early in the
morning press play and let's get it in
cause we rocking with the fighter
[Music]
yeah actually hard bro i will not put on
a white t-shirt right now
why you won't you won't put a white tee
on jump over the pool [ __ ] no
i won't put on a white tee because it i
don't it does
you know black is slimming is what i'm
saying all right you're looking skinnier
though yeah ready
i know we was looking at a [ __ ] uh a
little brows video and was in san marcos
san marcos and chappelle had this like
blue oasis sweatshirt on uh is he the
one on the side yeah
on the side of that [ __ ] he looked like
big
that's when you were like now i'm 255's
like i'm telling you
i probably i promise you daddy you're
not it was pretty fast i was like
what's that girl willy wonka's chocolate
factory when she was like i don't know
yeah
violet yeah you look like violet or that
now there's been some of the so yeah
that's but that's how you know like you
don't know because you live with it
every day
yeah you don't know someone to take
pictures on stage like god i know yeah
because what are you saying you know
because i haven't been like taking
pictures of like my progress because i
was like i just want to [ __ ] do it
yeah you know but i saw that and i was
like god damn
even i noticed that i'm like god dude
what the [ __ ] was i doing yeah like when
i was at my baby
every [ __ ] morning when i was at my
biggest you know i'd hire a photographer
for the uh
the shows like which ones do you like
i'd like not
just this one he's like out of 400 pigs
that works for me
what's this just a chappelle in the
background watch
this is us and why chappelle on the side
look at how [ __ ] bad
is that by the way look at these
[Music]
browsers
i didn't know but look at chapel he's
stiffer to me
what the [ __ ] was i doing
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh
is that reuben stuttered from american
idol
that's throne shot
to be fair brendan didn't tell you
before any of us did he did yeah he did
it
you didn't tell me right there yeah i
tried i didn't want a fat shame i was
like
you getting big man oh that's how you
just hey dog you're getting big
that means anything i could be getting
buffed you know how long y'all was
trying to get on this wait but you
weren't lifting
no i wouldn't make sense i know it
doesn't make sense that is true when you
say i'm getting big i'm like damn man
you're like damn thanks i am
how about justin saul uh wednesday's
podcast like man y'all
[ __ ] up he said y'all gonna call me
unique looking
i said to be fair mal brought up your
face he said dog
he said i'm the i'm the top two best
leading comedians in the game and it
just went silent
i was gonna i didn't i would have said
that yeah i was gonna burn him but then
i was like he suffered
top two he just went solid all the hell
i was like oh i read that
top two yeah he said he's top two
justin's going through some [ __ ]
hey that's like that shitty rapper when
they call the breakfast club and they're
just terrible
yeah they're just awful i'm the hottest
rapper in the game yeah you know
charlemagne is always honest to him oh
he's like you trash you know that was
bad
he's he's like he did that he goes don't
quit your day job man the guy's like man
[ __ ] you and they just cut him off
he did it to that one actor ah [ __ ] uh
was it la keith or kevin stanfield keith
yeah yeah that guy he did it's him yeah
they got beef oh he's from that uh uh
messiah judas
the black yeah that's right yeah he did
he did like a freestyle for charlemagne
and it was bad
and charming goes that's true
i love him i love him
he sat there and watched the whole time
was just that and he goes that ain't it
he let him finish it is there anything
we're saying
what what you know you wrote those
lyrics like
all night practicing in the hotel you
know just in case they call me out you
know i'm ready
trust me i know where do you go from
there
i disagree all right cool
i'm the biggest voice of music i say it
ain't it you got it yeah it's so funny
as far as charlemagne goes voice in
music like current like relevancy
the breakfast club is big yeah it is big
brother there's who ebo
right here bro he's pretty big too
like he's staying on breakfast club
level like who's
in l.a there's nick cannon big boy but
nick can't really put people on like
charlemagne big boy big boy big boy's
not big anymore
what he was like you in that rap video
and then now he's like super skinny
yeah he lost a [ __ ] load of weight you
know he's a guy he has one of those
memories i forget who
is like this but once he meets you once
he never forgets you
he's like i met him at like some random
[ __ ]
he's like oh what's up man we're talking
he's like all right he was like what's
your name
well brent shaw he's like yeah i know
you man boy
five years later i'm walking and do
something he's like what's up brendan
shaw i'm like
what whoa yeah then i was talking to his
assistant god damn
i was talking to his assistant and
they're like he's like that with
everyone man he never forgets the name
right that's [ __ ] dope oh my god damn
that's
i'm i have the opposite i wanted i saw a
big boy on a nissan
dude he was the biggest boy
damn that's yeah well big boy big boy
man yeah
i'll tell you what though now that nick
cannon's back after his uh
haters after his anti-semitic rant
yeah yeah you go on vacation he's
killing him he's killing it
i have a routine i listen to him and uh
you know on the mornings driving in i
was in a breakfast club when i go home
oh you do yep oh you stay on it like
that that's my routine you know what
charlemagne's driving a little nuts
because he's so anti-white so it's
hard to i mean dude he calls them uh
uh isis crackers like anyone who's white
because of isis crackers
i'm gonna call it charlemagne you'll be
cool man
not all of us are [ __ ] right what
color are you
no um wait what the [ __ ] was i just
gonna say
you talking about like nick cannon oh
yeah i was like dude he's [ __ ]
talented
he'll he'll find his [ __ ] way he'll
he'd find his [ __ ] wadding out his
body i mean i know
a lot of his [ __ ] got [ __ ] taken but
it's like well now he's coming back they
did they
wasn't that something that they took
away too yes originally
yeah he said they stole it from him my
name is he said
who stole it from mtv yeah because he it
he created it yeah he's a [ __ ] how
much is he worth
well first of all he when he got
divorced from mariah carey got paid
and then he got paid off that oh yeah
why because it's mariah carey
they had kids how did he get because
she's the richer one yeah because she
makes more money
is that what happens through divorce
yeah it's whoever makes it more money
that was a lot of money that worth 30
million if you haven't made a ton of
money in our radio shacks
really radio shacks
he used to own all radio shacks for a
while oh wow i didn't know that
he's a beast man i need to get on the
channel level what the [ __ ] am i doing
man yeah i watch on the clock i think
how long he's been hustling doug
yeah he's been in it for a minute he's
not i don't even think he's 40 yet and
he has team nick
right is he 40 yet i'll check it right
now he's 40.
uh the best picture is when he's at that
game and he got he went too african
and jay-z and beyonce are looking crazy
oh really
he's in like uh oh he is 40. he's 40.
damn
gosh damn right 52. rise 52. and look
look 30. now you want to talk about
someone who has a
list of ladies yeah
really dude i mean name somebody kim
kardashian kim k
oh yeah yeah christina milian sierra
sierra i think he didn't see her for a
hot minute name any hot girl
nick cannons ran through that god damn
all the water now girls
that's how you get a job i heard what
for real i mean why wouldn't you no i
don't know anything
i'm sure they'll probably keep sure
those parties get pretty loose
yeah but once that [ __ ] cuts off they do
the while now party i bet that [ __ ] is
so lit you think
there's so many baddies on while now
yeah come back oh obj's current
girlfriend used to be a walling out girl
yep
really bad girls
and you know he go to texas to recruit
these wildlife girls
he does that's where he gets them man
texas where's that they have like a
uh tryouts oh there goes are you guys
doing auditions soon
how do you get to be a while another
girl just be a badass it's got to be a
better kind of like audition for
getting the club at in vegas basically
and which one's obj's girl uh she's not
doing this
she's an older one you would probably
have to look her up instead type in lolo
wood
lolo wood yeah she bad is she like yeah
she's like 26. she's in the military too
oh that's why she's so tall
what that's his girl yeah that's his
girl dudes
odell beckham for god's sakes oh she's
super bad
is she is she light skinned i can't tell
i can't tell she's like puerto rican
something like that or a dominican she's
like uh oh my god that's all we need to
know
yeah she's doing something right yep he
got off a while enough so
let your dreams fly but yeah uh so he
goes
[Music]
is it too early for this no no
oh man well that's nice
that's nice
i mean like what i mean that's this
that's
yeah she she was put on this earth for i
would know
i was ready for it i'm going to say that
you started put on this earth
man because just to protect our country
as a
veteran she was a marine oh she's just i
know she was in the air force
oh she was uh oh there they are look at
that there they are
here's some stussy
she's snatching just out there being
good-looking people look at her with the
pink hair copying my girl
oh yeah joe has pink hair looks so good
big hair copy of my girl
although she did it before i see you
talk
yeah i didn't know you can't get it like
my girl there you go yeah
i don't know love is type love it's
tight dog all right
oh the pink hair is in pinkie pink it
does look cool
she looks great and that is a uh uh
character am i allowed to like it
oh yeah okay i didn't know if i i said
cool mom
i'll respect that yeah i just out of
respect i just don't know if she comes
home and telling us mom i want my hair
like the
the the united states flag colors red
white
the [ __ ] that's the way kids think i was
like yeah man
yeah i want my hair like that yeah
without your hair that's a popsicle oh
yeah i've dyed my hair all right let's
take a little break from the shenanigans
cause guess what man
out there are a lot of wireless
headphones there's a ton
they probably came with your phone or
you see something on the on the freaking
tv tells you to buy this earphone
this this or that listen you can catch
me at zoo gym and you will see me
with raycon wireless earbuds in when you
see me on my bike i got raycon wireless
earbuds in my ears are all weird
and these are the only wireless earbuds
that fit my weird ass
ears they're great they're great sound
quality i can't recommend them enough
they're literally the only headphones i
use now when i'm flying riding my bike
working out whatever i'm doing and uh
it's raycon wireless raycons are built
to perform anywhere anytime
with water and sweat resistant
construction and bluetooth that appears
quickly and seamlessly
also they last forever with enough
battery life for six hours of play time
you can unplug for a while i listen to
all my podcasts with these things
the best part is raycon makes great
sound accessible to everyone with
wireless earbuds
start at half the price of other premium
audio brands
you guys know me i wouldn't have a
sponsor on the show if they weren't
legit
i use these every single day whether i'm
on my bike for the thick boy bike club
or i'm at the zoo culture gym these are
the headphones that i freaking use i
can't recommend them enough
raycon's offering 15 off all their
products for you guys the fire and kid
listeners
here's what you got to do to get it go
to buy raycon b-u-y-r-a-y-c-o-n dot com
slash
t-f-a-t-k that's it you get 15 off your
entire raycon order
so feel free to grab a pair and spare
that's 15 percent off at byraicon.com
t-f-a-t-k by raycon.com
t-f-a-t-k right here like that yeah yeah
without your hair that's a popsicle oh
yeah i've dried my hair oh you
had a bleach blonde yeah uh it was like
a
mint blue yeah when was it uh
years ago probably six years ago before
you were like never in brenda shop
no i don't know there it is that's not
mint blue
what it was like a platinum mint blue
that is not blue
oh you that's not platinum mint blue bro
that is [ __ ]
what no it's a tender
uh i don't know where that's at
firing the kid in the back what made you
do that yeah you kind of look like homie
from uh
jimmy neutron uh no uh america's next
top model what's that guy's name
oh mr j mister is that that guy's name
yeah that's what you look like oh that's
a good-looking fella yeah here's the
prom
is i uh i did that when i jumped in the
ocean
is it and what happened that's ariana
grande really [ __ ] it up no that's not
her brother
oh i jumped in the ocean and like just
took out all the color and like
made it like white blonde oh really it
was a disaster you know what i decided
since y'all calling me ugly
the other day yeah bro i'm cutting my
[ __ ] hair
thank god i mean though well that's why
we did it because i looked at that
i posted a picture of dave chappelle as
a reggie
professor on my story oh he did and i
said
now look at brenda shaw said i look like
this and people like
it's your world dog it's your world dog
first of all that goes hard as [ __ ]
look at this
we're talking to the group i gotta cut
it i gotta cut it yeah i don't know what
are you gonna do
i need to figure something out
originally remember you were gonna do
uh braids like uh i think i'd go back to
skinhead like i was go to that picture
i'm gonna go
shave shave yeah maybe i could do
skinhead like right
right there does your girl care she
likes me with hair
but i don't know how to [ __ ] do it i
don't know what to do with my [ __ ]
hair because i don't know hairstyles
like that
so i'm just [ __ ] ugly right now no no
no no no no no way let them get up
no don't do that bro people were pissing
me off they were like man you really a
10 you were 10 you were 10 i said shut
the [ __ ] up
because it's like be honest be honest
with me
you're here people that were saying five
and six i was like thank you thank you
thank you
i'm on my way people were saying are you
a five or six dog
yeah they say la are just like ringing i
just said five six
i mean cause you don't know what they
are they didn't probably someone did say
i was a texas 8.5
though so oh yeah we are in texas soon
yeah but no but yeah i don't know i
gotta cut i gotta cut my hair man i i
look too raggedy yeah
i thought i was looking good yeah but
you know it's that it's that ugly shame
and you did yeah
someone said it was like this fat shame
and this ugly shaymin all these stranger
things what else you got to shame about
me dawg that's it man
that's it is that it that's is that it
brendan we just got to figure out what
style to go with
like what's popping right now i don't
know what what michael b jordan got
ooh that's that that one's good but this
is no no the michael b jordan haircut
when he played uh
in that superhero movie what's
supernatural talking about black the
black panther black black black panther
is killmonger oh you come on i think
that looks cool we'll see what it looks
like
do you want charcoal we're gonna have to
find the right barber dude
i got this we can find someone something
you look like we'll
i don't know who that is ooh you're
going to have to go out your hair for a
while that looks tight though here's
nowhere near
that long should i do that that's going
to take
like two years like a yeah like at least
a year to grow out i feel like
but he had fake hair yeah that's fake
unless you want to wear this oh yeah you
can weave hair in your head
i could break it down yeah put a weave
in my hair i wanna i like my [ __ ]
natural
i keep my gap natural my skin tone
natural my [ __ ] hair natural
[ __ ] out of all the haircuts if you
joined in
[ __ ] we've never talked about it
before right i think it looks tight
though yeah they look like they do
but yeah i can't [ __ ] do what bart
marley did man
i mean yeah we'll look forward to that
chin let's do what bob marley did yeah
yeah dude just do that no i can't get to
that
that takes forever yeah i don't know
that's so much damage on i
i just know i need to [ __ ] cut it i
just know this is not my look
it's definitely i thought it was my look
but it's not my look yeah your hair's
getting long too yeah your hair's
getting long what are you going to fro
yeah yours ain't great right now homeboy
you know who has a good you know what
that's a good hairstyle diddy
diddy yeah like waves that's it i
couldn't no no no
no he's doing this yeah
you know that surgery as well though
wait should i do the mohawk no
absolutely not no please don't i love
why you just shut him down
all right chill dude you know he is ways
what are you talking yeah he just has
waves what are you talking about
but like for for for a simple man like
me i'm a simple [ __ ] man
would you like the drake haircut where
it's kind of just like a design in it
that's cool too i think what is
champagne poppy that's just yeah yeah
come on chan i know dude
i don't know these things it's just a
high taper with a little heart
with like a heart on it but you got to
have waves though would you
chill on the waves i'll get those okay
he does have like waves on top right
yeah that is the hope and that's that's
not
amg that's what i need to do i need yeah
i got to figure something to [ __ ] out
because yeah literally i i yeah i don't
think i i was watching old clips and all
this [ __ ] just
i don't have good hair i mean that's it
behind you remember you had your hair
cut like that
go turn around right behind this black
and white people with the sombrero
i thought you were talking about my i
was like yeah that was nice that's what
the [ __ ] is that
that was a [ __ ] it's all nappy no it
wasn't yes
okay look at look at drake though
but you know what you know what else i
suck at too fashion
yeah yeah
i still get finding pants [ __ ] shirts
all i wear is band t-shirts you read
which i probably will wear
for that's your vibe i always i can't
not rock a band t-shirt i just can't
help you you stay on them sweats though
how about if i say hey you ain't gonna
wear sweats on stage are you
you do you know why i wear the sweats
because my [ __ ] pants
they suck they they don't fit no because
i'm losing weight and so they just look
real baggy on you at 38 we gotta find
jeans
yes this is this is gonna be a chappelle
makeover makeover
oh i like this you like that i like it
what you thinking i think you should
like get rid of the uh beard
you know what i mean because it doesn't
go all the way like clean shave
had a little mustache little goatee at
the bottom cut that off top of your head
for sure
we just need pants yeah that's the only
thing that really
yeah i can't wear pants from there you
picked some
they didn't fit and jay bought those
expensive ass basketball store
yeah he's like you know i just you know
he's like i've
i have wanted these yeah i don't know
what i have
dude i don't give a [ __ ]
just get him for god's sake i like how
jay explains his purchases
i wouldn't give you the glasses yeah no
he didn't give him though
yeah yeah
i never wear shades so you have even
when you're driving
yeah wearing one oh no i never wear them
now you know though no now i do because
if
if someone gives me some cool shades if
someone gives me something i'm [ __ ]
you know
yeah i'll use it and i'm [ __ ] no no
you
uh you mark miss the second day in a row
of working out okay first video of them
working out yesterday yeah exactly we go
late on me
oh bro do you know how far it is for me
to drive the zoo culture
yeah you say let's record at 10 and then
you're like let's work out at eight
bro there's no way there's no way we're
in it because
i leave at nine like if we if we're
recording at 10
i leave my house at nine that's a good
time that takes you how long you get
here
uh what like thirty twenty thirty forty
yeah thirty minutes yeah
terrible so yeah so yeah you want me to
drive all the way from zoo culture
to [ __ ] grab him right now because
you gotta pick him up but we stayed we
stayed five minutes away though we stay
we stay five minutes away so
that's not what you could have went from
zoo to the studio
or no no all right cause then i'm all
sweaty and [ __ ] like you get the shower
you get the shower no i would have left
straight from there i had to leave
straight from there
but you look all good and [ __ ] right now
were you comfortable in that white
little two cops a little too comfortable
in the [ __ ] white you're a little bit
i know
your body's changing i will not [ __ ]
put on a white t-shirt you can always
wear
you always a white t-shirt what are you
wearing haynes yeah jordan classic
haynes
without the tag from torque from target
from target
target yeah my girl says target as well
what is that is that i think my mom when
i was a kid always said target
sound
same parking you you go to target a lot
yeah
target is where is that target has great
stuff it's a dope
stuff they don't it's exhausting to me
what
it's just dude if i'm single i'm going
to target dude one by my crib
the workers there are so bad really you
get the workers the
shoppers the shoppers dude it is lit as
[ __ ] also you like all those band t's
they have
millions of banters i would never buy a
band t from target oh i'm
sorry i'm sorry hot topic
either i'm sorry how dare you
i'm
they're still killing it i guess no
they're not i don't know there's no way
they have pants there they have joggers
but they don't have pants that [ __ ]
fit me i don't know why why is it why
why do these places not [ __ ] with people
with big thighs
no yeah you got wild stuff i got white
hips yeah
do one yes like yeah you do [ __ ] i know
we just gotta you just gotta find one
brand that works and just stay on that
for life
i think g stars i haven't haven't
[ __ ] found a brand new
stars or uh the hudson's no not big and
tall
he's not that big or at all yeah but i'm
saying that
you don't want big and tall those pants
are huge
you ever seen the people that work at
big and tall and i got to compliment you
that's a comment you know what you said
they used to be sponsored i used to be
like their speaker i was like the the
who'd you say i was like the guy but i
didn't make a talk
but but i didn't realize big and tall
was like a dog
they had like nine x's yeah yeah and
they're like well
one of the benefits of being you know
sponsored by big and tall you can have
any clothes you want in here so go
go wild nothing fit it was yeah i want
to see the models
it's closed for like shaquille o'neal
dude oh no there's
or i don't need that or like pound life
tlc sponsored by big and tall did they
change their name
to kingdom i don't want out of business
no this is a covenant they're still in
culver city fox seals mall
yeah they got good deals well this is
king size
but that's what it's called
[Laughter]
what the [ __ ] and it's like regular
stuff they have in it like
yeah it could be stuff you get it like
polo stores but
yeah it looks like i would never [ __ ]
that doesn't i'm done you can't wear
that stuff no it's so big it's just too
big i have to get everything tailored
yeah now [ __ ] that it's a nightmare yeah
i don't think like i think hudson's or
g-star is going to fit you
guarantee it so this is my my lower body
when we get out here i'll send you links
to some
pants that'll fit cheerleading man did
this to my [ __ ] lower body
and now lifting and now lifting yeah
that's just [ __ ] big
i try to get those one pants broken kids
don't take fast advice
from broken on everything else
business-wise but not fashion but not
fast he also has terrible fashion he
knows this
god damn he knows this
you being anti-fashion is a style like
you with your barbell jeans and the
fanny pack and the
t-shirts is a style dog yeah like that's
your style
but i don't even look it doesn't even
look like i could fit those pants
actually those go
that guy looks like they might kind of
be like fashion nova jeans where they're
stretchy
so it looks like i need elastic jeans
now no there's some stretchiness and
like
g-star has like uh stretchy in their
jeans
that's what you need you know what then
don't wash them don't watch them you
know in a couple weeks i'm gonna come in
full on makeover
it'll be dope you know but really all
you do is cut your hair and get some new
yeah i just don't know how i'm gonna cut
my hair well i know
maybe maybe go to the barber and just
see see what they think
sometimes they're like dude your head
would look dope with this yeah because
my head yeah that's the thing is my head
shape i don't wanna just do something
that doesn't
match with my head shape yeah see what
they say you know what i mean
maybe i could do a split down the middle
and just [ __ ] oh
and what do what and what is that i
don't know
it's time to figure it out but did
somebody make a mood board for what
chappelle's hair was gonna be
like you just gotta find a really good
barber and be like hey man
i don't know what the [ __ ] do with my
hair and let him do it you what's so
wild about you is you [ __ ]
don't wear jeans at all i know but like
you're sweating but you have
great fashion not really i just typical
fashion i know i hate jeans
i hate jeans because but if you rolled
up somewhere like you rolled up like
that
people like damn he looks good but you
gotta have like some places ain't gonna
let you in like rolled up like
well if you got ovo sweats they let you
oh look at that pants
okay oh i like it the odell beckham so
you can dye your hair in the middle with
them
that would be where so this one's the
idea yeah right so i could do that yeah
so what do i need to do well also you
need to go to stylist
that's gonna be a real procedure that is
yeah we gotta
we gotta we gotta we gotta crisp the
tips what about day job you gotta start
over though because your hair is uneven
no yes he does cause look in the back
for the mohawk listen
hold on go back to you he doesn't have
that look at it right there he has to
all right
i'm gonna start all over no we'll do it
no we'll do a baby one
he just won't have the back you can do
the top you don't need the back like his
all right all right i just don't want
you to look like synthetic shot
chin cuts his own hair i know he does i
do but i don't have any hair right now
so that's the wakanda's team that's why
yeah
this looks tight i'm telling you that's
not jason derulo yeah
oh he's a diamond i'm just i'm just i
don't know i i think i have body just
dysmorphia yeah is that where i don't
like my body
where you see something else yeah i
think not lucky
i think most people have that unless
you're a complete narcissist yeah what's
i thought it was like a rarity i
guarantee even the rock wakes up like
the mirror like god i look fat
really guaranteed bro you so yeah i just
yeah i like i mean i feel better don't
give up i bet if you asked brad pitt
he's like guy look like [ __ ] today
everyone's like what
how does malik feel how about what your
body i feel
i like it i love it actually
no no i'm not no he just has that
healthy relationship with his body image
yeah and for me but they body shamed me
as far as like i was being too i'm too
skinny yeah and i was like okay cool
now but you're self-conscious your legs
you never wake up and look in the
bearing your legs and like damn these
are possible
i'm gonna have to bring you back down
i woke up this morning i was like oh the
valley climbed up here and brendan was
like hey
yeah exactly i was like that wasn't a
goodbye
self-conscious of something helping me
be better exactly
physically and you know fashion hey
hating yourself is healthy especially
for a comic
yeah i mean we kind of have to yeah we
have to because you have a lot
that's how we that's how we're aware of
[ __ ] yeah you got to be aware of who you
are
i woke up this morning and my girl's
like yo you got a little tush on you
like that's how i'm
it's the salmon you've been eating
i told you babe i told you give me a
couple of men by my legs i'm talking
right back with you
you know i have been talking right
the stallion
y'all later
i feel like even that's racist
yeah nah he said no i got a little
bit shut up i went to uh i went to
this gym yesterday and then uh like i
fit in like these guys was like doing
like
sets right uh-huh chess so you know me
i'm positive about my channel
jumped in i jumped in jumped in you said
i fall in the way exactly now here's the
thing when i jumped in
this big dude right now this is what
threw me off i'm doing my bench press
he's already fully dressed on like you
know he do work out with hoodies so you
know you're trying to hide your muscles
but he saw me getting it like the same
way dude was supposed to spot me
he takes off his hoodie and his shirt
and i'm looking at i see nothing but
like
cut abs gorgeous and all that i'm like
white chicks when terry crews comes up
beneath them
about white chocolate yeah oh
[Applause]
uh uh what's that place right there on
uh la brea in santa monica right there
by my uh the crib
oh is it that outdoor one that's not
boxing burn
um terry crews jack that [ __ ] 55
years old jackie
super jacked and the dude grabbed his
ding-a-ling i know and he went on a
whole pr tour about it
yeah i thought i lost a little respect
for him yeah oh because they do grab me
yeah grab my ass or dick for a movie
what did you say yeah i see how many
agents or
parties you're at they grab your dick or
ass what part is you going
what happens man i'm like into
just roast them make fun of them that's
everywhere that's never had any
cheerleading i've never had me in any
parties oh you know dudes grab me
no one's ever grab you no well because
you're the one pushing them
pushing them like you're i'm so if it's
a pyramid you're not
you're not the cherry on the cake
you're the power power bottle so nobody
here
so nobody spirit fingers never wait
maybe no to your ass
no okay all right i had a i had a terry
cruise one today at zoo
this girl she was talking about some
show i did i'm talking she's batting i'm
talking her
and then just mandingo just comes out of
nowhere i text you mark
oh yeah black shadows
dude it was like i was some [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ]
shrimp she's like okay see you later i
was like all right
when i look over he's her just all right
yeah oh i'm gonna go now i'll see you
guys later that's what they do with zoo
is just like yo
i panicked that bro i gave her a hug and
i looked at him i bowed i got nervous
[Laughter]
you know what to do i literally laughed
out there
shoes wild bro damn they'll come up to
you let's say if i was in there and i
was talking to a girl like an instagram
influencer and i think this was her man
or
just you know an acquaintance something
the big deal rolled up i was like
big big baby bdd just vdd
what's up guys this is you oh damn
that's cool bruh
all right man get out it's so wild when
someone's so big
she's a smaller girl no oh then that
matches
but when the dude's like just massive
and they got bro you know andre drummond
used to date that girl from icarly yeah
that small girl
weird because she went on a whole pr
tour saying how she hates that show she
was she never did it
really stopped acting yeah pull up a
picture andre drummond and
what's her name casey uh jeanette well
that's like shaquille o'neal and uh
that's someone else yeah yeah casey
anthony someone else jeanette mccarty
yeah i can't see anything definitely
no i think he was a fan of the show and
he had a crush on her
he shot his shot online and they started
dating shortly after put it this way
she not bodied up she's not at all but
she got a
she got are they still together no no i
think it was like a short
bro i bet she was exhausted
dude that's look at that exactly that
that always shocks me because like
she was like here we go yes some girls
like accepting let me climb on top
get up there and she going bro oh i bet
she was just
yeah hell you tell her look at that he
probably telling
them yeah what's even more alarming than
that is uh shaquille o'neal and hoops
was bad that's even damn that's funny
seven two
and a half times who's got something
like she get you know
yeah icarly's tiny carly bro she got a
little like kylie probably
that's flat no hold on she probably no
no no no
look at that [ __ ] i'm starting to look
at now i'm noticing yeah
7-4 wait chin go to her
shack laying down he got her on uh you
have a baby
would you say it says hoop and shaq the
second one to the left
second one to the left i don't think i
have a baby this one go under underneath
uh-huh
hold on look at that dog
what the [ __ ] bro she's so small so
small shack no but shaq's just so big
that's what i'm saying so y'all don't
care about that bro
her i feel like she can handle whatever
he's giving her yeah icarly is like god
you're right if you go to flavor flavor
hope you make it girl shack
you say what shaq he ain't got no little
weight check right there but but even
this
if you're seven four like this ain't
that's not that's not
like to scale yeah he's seven four seven
two or seven four he's huge
yeah seven i think he's seven two seven
one wait i mean
still going in it going in an average
human
seven one though well what this is how
tall is this cup this probably i don't
know
but that going in like a girth well i
don't know if he has girth but
even the the length this is probably six
inches
a dollar six inches a dollar that's so
six inches a dollar is bigger than that
or smaller than that
i don't think so that might be like six
and a half seven if i have to guess
anyway either way yeah
that's damaged
ain't nothin
though
i don't see how they're gonna do it i
just don't trust me they figure it that
shit's
always wild to me yeah i've seen way
wilder
just finished the video like how's this
gonna figure out i don't get just to
watch it how's it gonna fit
i watched the porn so it got me it
turned me off
because it was so paul's it was so i'm
like girl and she and then it needs so
much blood
it like bends in the middle it's like
yeah think if you have a long
like if you build like a long black coat
it gets weak in the middle we get a
little yeah
you don't have the yeah
yeah so even but even that dick it's so
long it like
bends down like it's so heavy it looks
like a like a
like a what a tree trunk you know when
they get real heavy snow on them that
was this guy's day i was like poor girl
cuz she tried to give him head and she
was
barely like pitching his mic and she's
just like go right here
but barely anything barely and for him
i'm like this can't be great
he's got a mouth oh yeah
then she had to get up there and they
had to like hold on and it was like took
like five minutes for her to just like
finally and she didn't go all the way
through it i was like nah this is her
way she turned red i'm like oh
i hope those ladies get extra money for
going for the mandinga
they better they're probably they're
being paid more than he is they better
be your email's always been it better be
for sure because that hurt me i'm like
no way yeah
ain't no way there was that guy the
mandingo on um
oh what was it not brazier's another one
um what are there more than one mending
groups yeah there's the
the famous mandingo there's the mandigo
now but there was one ultimate like og
yeah they get older oh do you like pass
the torch to like the next generation
i think it's just a porno like from if
you have just a [ __ ]
i see mike that was icy mike [ __ ] that
guy in there named mandiga and just like
oh man i don't know it's too much
yeah i would hate my life if i had that
bro think about it you know you have a
big ass
you you wouldn't no that big yeah yeah
you scare girls away you that's what i'm
saying
big dicks are disgusting am i right guys
come on girl
watch this podcast what is chappelle
talking about
no no i would hate it you would yeah why
yeah no
if it was that massive yeah yeah that's
uncomfortable yeah that's uncomfortable
yeah cause i was watching ferrari
[ __ ] nah that's a dump truck
yeah that's not that's 18 wheeler that's
that's that's that's that's that's the
key 18 wheeler yeah
you gotta have an extra license to drive
no
that girl was panicking too but yeah you
probably run so many girls away
think about a guy that's not a porn star
that just has that
he's running girls away well that's why
you probably go into porn though
maybe yeah they got a guy called punish
her
huh yeah his nickname is punisher
punisher
wow
[Laughter]
though sometimes i see a gang bang of
all black guys one white girl
the guys
[Music]
for
like four or five guys i'm like leave
something for me dog oh you [ __ ] hurt
i'm like god yeah but
you hitting that dog you see them
there's no way people just enjoy it oh
you hear one homie go yeah suck that
dick
but it's not his dick yeah y'all
yeah i love when the dude's just like
take that [ __ ] girl take off i'll be
like yo
shut up yeah i bet god can you pipe it
out it's already awkward in here
i love you yeah your friends yeah your
friend jerome we don't know jerome
you don't get that big ass kicked over
there man hurting this boy
okay jerome she had to sign the waiver
when jerome came
i love when the dude don't have nothing
to do and then all her holes is filled
he'll just come over there and just
smack the ass
oh yeah you're sleeping in the back
jacking up
just just foaming at the mouth to get in
there yeah
damn that's so [ __ ] funny dog oh my
god i'll win the
game i know this is stupid well i know
when like the girl's getting hit from
behind
and the dude getting hit and she just
take a break and then she's like oh [ __ ]
just keep hitting it he's like man just
try he tried to weasel the dick back in
her mouth
or even she takes a small break yeah
like yeah and then he's like let me just
get one more
let me recoup all right there's like
time
hold up everyone chill everyone's gonna
get service
but you gotta give me time i'm getting
baby she's better
but she better make a million off that
oh no she made 700 bucks
[Laughter]
i'm trying to tell you they better give
her a [ __ ] bill no he's so funny some
of those german
no i really don't know you're serious
yeah all right chin
everyone knows cocky right yeah yeah oh
why are you saying no i was just
shocked what the [ __ ]
how do you not know what to do
[Applause]
are you [ __ ]
like a bunch of people coming on a girl
yes it's like just
all together why don't they just just
call it that
because it's a japanese term right i
think it's a joke yeah
let me look what it means you see you
know just go to the images you see
you see the girl just like ugh i'm icing
icing icing
japanese like cinnabon active splashing
that's what oh that's cool i'll show the
name of a noodle dish
yeah so it's a
dish and they just stole the name but
it's called action
yeah actually the boys so if you jump
into a pool that's a [ __ ]
yeah yeah i just want to say we're
interested in canada
because all the guys go on stand man
let's boo cocky this thing
people enjoy that bro it's just like
some girls
yeah i don't know we never hear from
them
now glory hole is where it's a door and
you have a
dick yeah so i know that sometimes just
a bunch of holes
oh yeah yeah it's just a bunch of dicks
they had a gory
glory hole in louisiana really yeah
that's it they had a glory hole in
louisiana
now i ain't want to you don't know who
your boys are like man behind that thing
that was like bro hey you can get lit
and you gotta pay it's like
a hundred dollars i'm not gonna pay a
hundred dollars for no
yeah yeah i'm glad i'm not that horny
i'd have to see
oh well of course it's going to be girls
but i was in louisiana paddy so it was
popping that night he was like bro 100
it's like what 2015 and i was like all
right and i know about glory holes
i wanted to so bad but i have like all i
had was a 50. i just feel bad for the
girl
well yeah you getting paid for them
always a girl you get paid though
that's what i'm saying yeah is it
there's a lot of gay glory holes yeah
that's what i assume it's like a guy
pretending to be a girl
that's why i said i you you have to
stick your hand up first and that's
i can feel through the hands
all right well you're clearly a dude
that's a different level of horniness
yeah i don't [ __ ] yeah that's [ __ ]
that's a lot it's aggressive
mm-hmm yeah that's a lot it's a lot
yeah it's a different level yeah to be
that yeah i want to say
regular regular sex is funny gang bangs
is not i'm not comfortable with gang
bang i never ran
i never had another guy with me i'm not
no i'm
that's scary why i need to be i'm
spelled just learn what [ __ ] is
you're right take it back take it back
you're right it's an overload i know
right you just dropped so
this girl's not gonna allow him on the
show who are you hanging around
and be like babe you know what
i do and it's disgusting well
keep saying where the splash bros
your girls are gonna let you on the show
get some current events
oh that's so funny oh gosh okay
so uh some people are upset because
draymond green did an
interview where he says that uh women
athletes should take more action
instead of paying a complaining about
the pay gap and what he means by that
is um he's all for women getting paid
more and getting paid
what they think they're worth but he
doesn't like that
he hears a lot of these female athletes
coming out and talking about how they
need to get paid
and still play and they don't take
advantage of the same thing with the ufc
exact same to a t i'm with draymond
green on this
complain complain yet you still
participate like let's say
you were you were you're upset about
your pay but you still
showed up and did the show every day
yeah i'm not gonna do i'm gonna keep
paying yeah because it's like yeah
because you're not gonna do [ __ ] because
it's like how serious are you about it
yeah
so you're not gonna complain on every
platforming complaint yet you still play
every day yeah
you're still playing or you're still
doing the podcast every day so people
are mad at draymond
i think a lot of people like saw the
headline of like oh he thinks women are
complaining about the pay gap and they
took that out of context
for him he's saying more like in this
day and age there are so many companies
out here
trying to look like they're inclusive
saying like oh we believe that women
should get paid more this and that like
tell those companies to put their money
where their mouth is exploit them trying
to
look good in the public oh got without
so all they saw was taking advantage of
people saying like oh we think women
should get paid more like if
uh yeah he's right nike says women
should get paid more the
pay gap the pay gap is [ __ ] up
meanwhile like call nike out on it and
say like you'll
pay us more yeah they're nike then pay
your athletes the same that you pay
drake and jordan
that's what draymond's saying he's not
saying that women he's absolutely just
complaining he's oh god
but now if you're a nike when it comes
down to black and white bottom dollar
they're gonna go well
the reason why we don't pay them as much
because they don't bring the same
numbers
but it's pretty easy to figure out wma
we've seen this before it doesn't bring
anywhere near the viewership men's do
so if i'm a sponsor i'm not paying wnba
the same paying mba
and it's not a female male thing it's
just that organization doesn't bring as
much as this organization
this organization just has to be but do
you think do you think that's because of
the lack of pay
no no no one's watching america tells
you what's popping
the world tells you what's popping no
one's paying attention to it so if
you're an advertiser why would you pay
the same price for something that's like
in the same viewership but i mean it's
i never see it it's very black and white
same as this so if someone came to this
show was like hey
we'll give you a million dollars and
then another show that only goes
gets a thousand downloads i think like
well
because we're three women we should be
the same as we should get paid the same
as chappelle malek and brendan
that advertising like well no they get
more views yeah but we're women
okay you don't get the same amount of
views yeah so why why would we pay this
much
yeah because we're women that we don't
care yeah we're just trying to sell
product
yeah i tried yeah
you know because the sponsors aren't
going to pay this thing well i mean
that's the union that's like wnba union
why they have an association that you
got the bargain agreement with these
owners to have more money
so like also now why don't the owners
have more money because they're not
selling tickets they're not getting
uh viewership on the their network but
how heavy are they
how heavy are they promoted though
they're promoting is that is that like
fair
it's not it's not fair to ask my green
actually talks about that a little bit
too he says
that he thinks a big problem with women
not getting paid enough
is that there isn't really like a
promotion
where you hear about these females
that's what i'm saying
yeah and he says that there are a lot of
like we think if they put the same
american dollars behind women's
wnba compared to men's mba get the same
viewership no it's not
out of your [ __ ] i don't think you
get the same but it'll probably go up
this is the don't think so because
everyone's aware of the wnba
yeah but we don't know when they're
playing when's that time you watch the
game i haven't watched the game and you
think it's just because you don't know
when it's airing no yeah exactly
you know the games come on early in the
morning at like 10 a.m when we wake up
like oh
it's a game on the wnba before the the
prime time games
so again on espn if they advertise now
yeah but i wouldn't
that's that's what i'm saying like it
like i don't watch football but i know
i know who some football players are i i
mean i only know brittany griner and
taurasi
and i don't you you know basketball
better than i do you know
she does there's some big names there
but look at look at the ufc
you know they they market the [ __ ] out
of their female champions now do they
get marketed the same as
say connor no why is that
because connor brings in more
pay-per-views but okay so
someone like amanda amanda nunes is
she's undisputed champ
not like the best we've ever seen
she she she's rolling though i'm sure
she does well
doesn't do nearly as well as the top 10
males
oh that's a great example christian
shields uh the one group she calls
herself
the other boxer box issues she called
out layla ali
that's a mega fight that's not a mega
fight in women's
that's not a mega fighter and women's i
don't know what world what woke world
you're living in that's not a mega fight
they try to push it how many people are
going to watch it that's what i'm that
was my point that's my point
they're gonna watch it they wanna make
they want and layla lee hasn't fought in
how long
yeah but again they're just she wants
some she said well i'll fight her for
like what 10 mil
and it was like we're not giving you
that title who's gonna pay that exactly
that's what they said
but again my thing is if if to the wnba
you can't have
if you don't like it you can't set it up
because you're stopping money to go you
don't have enough money to go on strike
all right vision complaint interviews
what's the highest paid
wnba player highest paid wnba
yeah like i guess like right now i think
they're uh what is like
the article said the salary average
salary for like a wnba
player i guess that's my question so 100
000
200 000 right yeah you want a boner what
do you want to bonner
or see two hundred thousand yeah she
she plays for the she makes 200 a year
yeah
for the season or uh sorry for a season
yeah that's how that
oh okay candace parker was the highest
uh
paid athlete wnba player
skyler diggins yeah she's not she's
she's dope she's hot
beautiful so the highest around 200
000 yeah but but again the top three i
know two of those
but again the the the reason why kyrie
irving and durant and lebron and paid
more look at the merch sales
yeah have you seen a brittany grinder
who have you seen anyone rocking a
britney grinder jersey
what's last time in arizona no you
haven't no you're
right thank you thank you
i like the effort
and brittany was she would get all the
money she would get all the money
like the public let you know you know
yeah
you don't even see those women
basketball jerseys i've never seen one i
was about to say
well you know what i'm gonna [ __ ] buy
one and wear it on the [ __ ] show what
are you saying huh are you serious would
that be weird no i'm just that'd be cool
yeah but they don't even sell it what do
you think you can
what for that jersey for a britney
grinder jersey they get all those things
do they have the size of men that's the
great that's the question i'm sure
okay that looks good
the black ones they look kind of hard i
like the like it was
aces att why is that why the logo has to
be like 18 ts would be on the jersey
like somebody get money oh
okay all right all right what else you
guys got
salute to them women mm-hmm
okay so do you remember we were talking
about uh michael strahan
um closing his gap so
it turns out it was an april fool's
prank that he launched
too early he posted it on march 30th
and then on april fools yesterday he
released a video
where he was talking about why he closed
his gap but then he took off his mask
and showed that it was just a prank
so like in a minute in is when he
reveals it
i mean i'd like to talk for a while i've
had it for almost 50 years now
and a lot of people out there is he
wearing a mask
because he's waiting for the reveal i'm
good about rocking mine and everything
else and
i know of the shocker to see it gone but
i just want to tell you guys that
um you know i appreciate all that love
that you show and and be you
live the way you want to live do what
makes you happy because i did
and i am happy um that that i did it
so i just wanted to say um
april fools come on man
[Laughter]
yeah it's here to stay for a little
while
i should have said the game not going
anywhere anytime soon so
april fool everybody i had a good time i
actually feel
bad i feel really bad about actually not
closing it after everything that i saw
but the gap is here the gap is not going
anywhere for a while uh my mama for a
while my mama my mama likes herself
there you go
damn i thought i moved up the first team
all gap bro
i was ready to take that [ __ ] spot
i'm like
i'm glad it was april fool's joke i like
going with the gap
i like the gap yeah people would guess
me uh well
yeah he's headed for what yeah his whole
life
that bellator ring girl remember her
jade bryce she has
like that's like the who the most
beautiful gap i saw in a girl oh that's
the most beautiful gap like
it actually works for her oh sorry for
women oh okay
all right he yelled at me for a [ __ ]
yeah yeah
she used to be a ring uh ringside she is
yeah
oh she still is no i don't think so
i know she had a baby ah she's not sure
there it is
oh that's a cute little oh that's a nice
gap
is that like mine can you see yourself i
feel like yours is a little bigger
barely pretty similar yeah you don't
have a crazy gap but
you have a great hands is huge if you
zoom in on that [ __ ]
[Laughter]
yeah she was uh smoking okay so
bad baby announced that she is coming
out with an
x-rated only fans uh she turned 18 i
think a day or two ago and she
launched it on her birthday within six
hours she broke the world record for
making a million dollars are you at cat
huh well yeah not a million
a million she made a million yeah she
posted on her story too
she was like this ain't bad in only six
hours it was a mill underneath
are you serious because uh she posted it
and she promoted her only fans on her
instagram that has 17 million followers
and she ended up making this much in six
hours
and she has she hasn't posted anything
uh i think she has uh i checked
yesterday she had eight posts as of last
night
so i was doing calculations based off of
this so in six hours she had
over 31 000 people subscribed to her and
out of that 31 000
people gave her tips through her
messages before she even really posted
before she even really posted it mm-hmm
that's how strong her fan base is she's
she's 18
now yeah yeah she's 18. she so she
she just strictly does music now yeah uh
she does music
and then she she just i feel like she
does other stuff
too but i'm just not quite sure what it
is yeah i know she was in the news
recently because she was calling out
dr phil for something he sent her to
therapy and she said like a therapy camp
and they were
and i would have dared my anger
management teacher to hit me yes you're
seeing how [ __ ] up it is
mm-hmm wow she's making bank now she's
making a bank
but she was hey she she's always been
making bank though she's been making
bank for a while now yeah
ever since that dr phil interview she
kind of took off running
she's the same don't feel the same age
as my youngest sister
and she's [ __ ] a multi-millionaire
yeah mm-hmm we're just a millionaire
slow down on multiplayer no multiplayer
she has to be bro yeah i knew her agent
she's here
30 million yeah her music was in her
music video yeah
yeah yeah i remember yeah we talked
about it multi-millionaire yeah she's a
multi-millionaire
as a minor but now she gets to she has
control over her
she's right she had a tour i think
because when they're young they can't
uh i think it depends there are
different rules depending on like
what entertainment you're in like kid
actors it all goes to a bank account
and nobody can touch it until you turn
18. only you can not even parents can't
touch it
that's the macaulay caulking rule yeah
oh yeah because this family [ __ ] a
moment that's right that's right
damn uh with only fans you have to be 18
to have a yeah you have to be 18.
yeah so a lot of people wait until like
the the day they're 18 and then launch
it
that's that's yeah what another [ __ ]
way she probably won't even post
anything
crazy probably she doesn't have to she
will no
i don't she can that's the thing she
doesn't have to
she's 18. there's no way i wouldn't i
mean i don't think she'd be posting
having sex on there but it's going to
get pretty
she posted this thing right so it looks
like she has no that's her tits out
coming out
i don't know let's just say the way
she's killing it
yeah salute what the [ __ ] was i doing at
18.
backflips they didn't have
hey 18 i was a dime [ __ ] yeah
but you're still not making money
[Applause]
no one knows who you are i don't know
who you are okay
uh so this is just stuff [ __ ] you just
like
damn there all right okay so uh
quavo and sawedy came out uh recently
because
when the elevator footage came out
apparently lapd got
got a hold of it and now they're
investigating that footage
both quavo and sweetie came out sweetie
said that
that was an unfortunate incident that
happened last year but they
uh talked it through they worked it out
they both have forgiven each other for
that situation
and they just want to move on they're
like it's it was
a bad time in what happened however we
got through it
like i'm not pressing charges or
anything i just want my privacy and he
said the same thing
where he was like i was not physically
abusive but we were in kind of like a
toxic
relationship so so lapd can't do
anything after that
i don't know i know that they're
investigating nobody's pressing charges
just because the footage came out got it
both sweetie and quavo just kind of want
to be left alone
yeah yeah i get it bro going back to
that wnba situation still on that yeah
i had an idea because i was thinking
about it like three articles ago and i
haven't been here
what if they have a transgender in the
wnba where ratings
go up think about it you mean like zion
williams with a that's what you're gonna
put a wig on like
again like wanna man situations like
exactly but and then they have like a
couple more
and then they dunk in they're doing
tricks and stuff like that cause like a
failed nba player like i'm not gonna
make it
and he just like change his identity
just like johanna man
okay exactly and then you have like a
league of them
and then that one okay keep going
that's horrible you get
get the
[Laughter]
all right so this happened you probably
don't want to look at this guy this
happened yesterday thursday night
uh some mma fighter fighting for cage
fury
him and his opponent were doing a hand
fighting whatever and apparently the
opponent broke his finger and then they
lost his finger
it literally came off in the case what
the [ __ ] would it come off
okay i'll show you the picture real
quick and they have a video
mm-hmm and a dude talking i gotta feed
here
so this is the one might be a little
tough for me
yeah this one that's what it looked like
afterwards it ripped off from the
knuckle it actually came off from the
knuckle yeah oh
that's what my daddy's hand looks like
really really yeah he lost a finger yeah
doing what snow blower oh yeah i know
stories
yeah but were you before you were born
yeah he was like 17.
wow okay weird how the [ __ ] would you
rip someone's finger off they said that
when they were doing hand fighting the
guy just
pulled his went to his glove and pulled
it off i know what is
crazy you know like i'm trying to grab
your hand off of my hand
and vice versa to rip a finger off
though
so straight ripped it off didn't even
know where it was because no they were
trying to find it they couldn't find
anywhere the guy threw it they
eventually
found it inside his glove somehow ended
up inside his glove
it's like a opponent's glove no his
glove oh his glove yeah his glove but
they stitched it back together oh that's
awesome yeah good for him
jesus christ first time ever i've never
heard of that i know
the best thing for him to do to re
rehabilitate is that to play guitar
yeah because uh a monkey from corn
i think something happened to him he
lost it in like a dirt bike accident or
something like that
and uh that's why he started playing
guitar oh
he said it was like a good way for him
to make sure he's rehabilitated
and then he blew up and then he he's
monkey from corn yeah
wow did the guy at least win the fight
no that's that's the messed up part
thanks for
reminding me his opponent juan because
it was like yeah
it was considered a tko yeah yeah so
he's gonna appeal it obviously
oh it's like when uh anderson silva when
he
uh would matter that that leg in this
[ __ ]
that matt chris they consider him to win
that fight because of that
yeah because he did it yeah yeah okay
basically you can't continue so
the other person wins so yeah so you
want what i mean this is kind of like
unique
yeah i took my finger off dude
all right i didn't even feel it in the
match it went back to this corner yeah
oh [ __ ]
too much adrenaline yeah too much yeah
so a real quick recap on the nike thing
with little nas x
so they have a temporary restraining
order on the production of the shoes and
i guess
right now they're asking that they just
whatever they have to be destroyed
and they can't sell these anymore well
they only made 666 of them they sold out
yep so i wonder for this company
mischief mischief i wonder if it's good
marketing for them
i would imagine so now they're in a
lawsuit with nike but it's dude
that's scary talking about this you
spoke on this yesterday once you get
into those battles with disney and nike
they have
endless money and you'll never win
you'll never win so is that great for
their pr in your marketing too
so here's some misjust pay for the cost
of the suit and lawyer fees
on top of the damages i'm not sure how
much damage is working yeah wonder what
nike's gonna be they're saying that they
could permanently mess up their you know
what do you call it their reputation
they said they could yeah
by doing these shoes yeah smart so yeah
about this job it's a terrible look
what's the first time i told you and jay
when we're in the green room in uh miami
jay's like you see those shoes like
there's no way nike's allowed that oh
yeah yeah you said that
you said there's no way corporate
companies not gonna put blood and shoes
or six six six no or they're not gonna
they're not gonna market satan didn't
they shoot
the ones that that made the god ones too
the jesus
jesus well that's the same company yeah
oh [ __ ] so they were all right with the
jesus ones but they're not fine with
this
i can imagine jesus once
slides they're like
all right uh i talked about this girl
before hannah kimura
so there was a show terrace house i told
you to watch the japanese reality show
on netflix uh so she ended up committing
suicide because of cyber bullying
wow and if you look into this guy so
he's charged 81 bucks
yeah so then check this out
the man cyber bullied kimura and then
he says stuff like hey when are you
going to die is there any value to your
life
and apparently he had 300 messages from
200 other accounts
just bombarding her just as one guy yeah
there's one guy
what i don't get with hers why was she
paying attention to this this happens a
lot with the
but why don't you just get away from it
it's hard with it with asian celebrities
yeah
what damn well how do you not have the
discipline just to be like oh this is
i'm sure some people do but some people
so they're just yeah they're just
affected too yeah why is asians like so
involved with
uh it's not just oh it's crazy it's but
it's not just asians it's it's americans
too
yeah but there's something there's a
community on social media and
especially in south korea where there's
so many avenues
and they all talk constantly doing the
cheeto fingers
damn and you're just hating on them
hating a lot of hate but we that's why
there's suicide
we have that here too i think it's way
more there it's way more even like
little things like faster internet
speeds more
more social platforms here we don't
like we see like that i don't know how
old she was but she's 22.
oh she's like now it's like young kids
are getting bullied yeah that's so we
don't know the repercussions of social
media yeah
because he's gonna start hitting these
young kids and their brain really [ __ ]
him up
[ __ ] that's a bummer it's a bummer
um here's this kanye west apparently
bought spotify i thought well me and jay
were talking about this that's fake
i think it's uh april fool's joke oh
okay because spotify is working
this is april first and kanye that's
what i'm saying yeah although
he's the richest african-american at six
million there's no way about that
and also notice how no big
outlet is picking this up yeah okay it
was oh
that's not real okay
i love kanye he can't afford spotify
oh what does this share a piece of no
that's fake
yeah it's fake huh definitely because it
would be all
yeah okay he doesn't have that much
money i think they're
they're that's way around 200 billion
dollars especially when
rogan came on they went up another few
billion yeah
because i found out about it because my
mom texts me goes so kanye's rogan's
boss i went what she was don't you have
the news i go
not your news did you get your news from
me
i see that on that then i'd take jam
like anything about kanye with spotify
he goes yeah i see it it can't be real
there's no way it would have been it'd
be all alone it'd be everywhere you
don't have that money
uh one more your boy tim kennedy he
posted this three days ago
about bare knuckle and then yesterday i
believe he posted this
against keith jardine yeah they're
they're former training partners
which is that what yeah he says he's
coming out of retirement to fight keith
jordan and bare knuckle
wow oh you know here's another thing too
one day ago
april fools oh that's fake yeah that's
fake for sure okay
but he posted three days ago and then so
that tim's not doing that
yeah so this is what he posted three
days ago okay but maybe he just built it
up said you did this last year on
april's fool's day
oh okay i freaking hated
it i hate it i'm too old
yeah what bro you remember you used to
get those i got to tell you something
on april fools is she pregnant
no dude you've been hanging what type of
girl
i know
no it's not it's hurtful oh anybody
watch godzilla versus king kong
that came on last night came out two
nights ago two nights yeah
june april first yeah i watched it it
was good it was good i heard that
it's entertaining it is it is what it is
it's a giant lizard and a giant gorilla
fighting each other so it is what it is
oh the critics was like yo there's a lot
of holes in the story and stuff i mean
listen i'm not looking for a great plot
line out of context yeah
who won who won it he could spoil it who
won no i'm not going to spoil it
it's [ __ ] good though for what it is
for what it is
like mindless entertainment yeah
probably the same as avengers all that
[ __ ]
yeah i won't watch it all right i'm
gonna watch it though
yes i mean oh also it's entertaining you
want to talk about entertainment you got
to watch the falcon in the winter
soldiers
[Applause]
that's marvel battle how did you like
superhero stuff that's why
it's just been in this series right yeah
yeah is he good
he's all right all right is he a main
character or no nah he's a psych
yeah i mean good for him they say that's
like the most strange
show yeah it's dope of all time on
streaming surfaces
there's only two episodes that came out
it's uh and friday what today is oh yeah
it comes out another two come out today
i have no desire to see that okay oh
somebody
dm'd me and said that we got rub maps
taken down
i don't know if this is true or not we
did that i didn't get rubbed sneaking
down
try and go to a chin because no i think
remember we went to the wrong
one yeah what do you think it was a
different one it was like ch yeah
i'm pretty sure so
[Music]
i don't think oh we also uh jay said we
got emails about women throwing
softballs i don't know what the [ __ ] you
googled
but women throw like 60 70 miles an hour
we said 25. they were sitting right
there and he saw what it said
i know i don't listen to google hey
i mean i'm not saying that i'm just
people like you're way off man they
throw like 60 or 70. all right hey shout
out to 60 and 70. you can't hit that
either
[ __ ] stain i'm just kidding they're
probably nice people that was rude
uh so is rub max down i think they
probably typed in the wrong
yeah they probably did calm like we did
the first time i don't know listen to
some freaks they're trying to get it
i
you'll be fine i think you just
explained it to him as well like hey bro
take his pants off make sure you know
there's a way to go man
uh all right man this crew is in naples
florida april 15th through 17th
naples florida and then austin texas
april 22nd through the 24th
the crew and special guest will be there
at the vulcan gas company
april 22nd through 24th take it to
fatkz.com
have a great weekend love you guys
it was beautiful outside go ahead
first oh [ __ ] i don't know i come clash
what are they
oh yeah you're good wait chin
you to walk a little dirty too wait no
now the pressure came on
the eyes
she's nervous now that's christina
christina
she gucci she gucci down with the
turtleneck
oh it's all about me oh uh malik b
rolly boy oh yeah see same old
same on here that's what he does i
usually just go over
see him oh there you go i mean something
slight on a friday
look yeah i mean nothing too much hey
you didn't prep her oh
i got you this christina don't even
confuse her with gina she got that
she got class yeah there it is
she got the turtleneck to make sure
y'all don't wreck go ahead yeah stay lit
love is tight you know what it is
yeah shout out to suplex for these man
these og ones i still gotta learn how to
tie these [ __ ] shoes because
you can't just try them
you can't tie them normally so i'll
figure it i'll figure it out
you coming with excuses though yeah all
right spelling
sweats
they're frosting uh naples
april 15th 17th austin april 22nd 24th
holla
boom